All over my city.
I've lived over my city.
Oh, I see.
Blood on
south side with
Soto.
For years, he's been known for his music.
But rapper
Jay-Z says his life has been so much more
than just about the music and success
that he enjoys now.
He's now speaking out about his life
before all of that,
his own mental health,
something you do not hear
very often
from the hip hop community
and a lot more is in his brand new book.
Here's
what he told me when I sat down with him.
Your first line is I can't even front.
I started out as a thief.
As a thief.
Now, my grandmother would say,
why are you telling everybody
your business? Right.
But why was it so important
for you
to be this real
and this raw with people
who picked up your book?
Well,
because I felt in the beginning
that I was dishonest
and I learned
as I went on that
life is about honesty and integrity.
And I was very ambitious back then.
So I thought that
taking something was actually a success,
but it was not.
And my grandmother
was the one that told me,
she said, I can deal with
anything, was a liar and a thief.
And I changed my mind
about that whole
a lot of our grandmothers
had some of the similar sayings
where that just wasn't something
they were willing to
to have somebody do in their life.
When people see you,
they think successful, like
this guy is out front
he's out there, he's doing his thing.
He's wearing a nice
gold watch, rose gold at that.
So they see these things
and they think, well,
if he can do it,
why can't all other black folks do it?
Why can't they rise?
What do you say to them?
Well, that's
that's why I wrote the book,
because I think when people see me,
they see the finished product.
And this has been 40 years of me
going through everything I went through.
And even a lot in the book is about how.
And the reason why I named the book
Adversity for Sale,
rather than let me show you my success
is because I want you to know
how many times I've lost
and continue to lose
and still keep the same enthusiasm.
And I feel like that
everyone black, white, brown,
whatever needs to hear that.
Even when you thought
that I was on top of the world,
the world was on top of me.
So even when I was at my highest,
I was at my lowest.
And I wanted people to understand that
you know, it is it
life is not perfect,
is not fair, is hard, but it's not fair.
And what I'm saying is hard,
but it's fair, right?
And you got to continue to believe
and keep pushing
because that's what my stories about.
I didn't want to tell people about
the finished product.
I want to tell them about how I got here.
You talk about paranoia in your book.
I got that far. Okay.
You talk about paranoia in your book
and the fact that you yourself
are really paranoid for so several years.
Yes.
Now, it's a really uncomfortable feeling.
Do you think, though, that
that fueled you
or that that started to break you down?
Well, it was a little bit of paranoia,
a whole lot of post-traumatic stress,
a whole lot of trauma,
depression, anxiety, all those things.
Well, I will say this.
The thing
that got me on my journey to healing
is that I started to learn
and understand what I was going through,
because before that,
I actually still thought
something was wrong with me.
Like, when you come from poverty,
this is how you're supposed to feel.
But I started to understand that
it was terms
and it was things that you can do
to help with these things.
That's why I put a lot of it in the book,
because as a black man,
where you come from,
where we come from
is almost weak to help people, help you,
you know, work through things. Right.
And for me,
I had to learned that the hard way,
that everybody needs some help.
And I didn't know I had trauma.
I didn't know I was depressed.
I didn't know I had anxiety.
I didn't know
I had post-traumatic stress.
I thought,
these are all the things
that we go through.
You thought it was normal
because it was
because where you grew up
and the life you led
was the normal their normal lives.
And so for so it was normalized.
And, you know,
when you lose your friends at a young age
and even in your adulthood and,
you know, people that are around
and they're going away doing 20,
30 years in prison,
and coming back like it's a normal thing.
Like you don't understand
how desensitized you are.
And as you get
older into your adult life,
you wonder where things are coming from,
but it's actually
coming from your young adulthood.
And I had to go deal with that.
And like they say, if you ain't never
seen a double face to face,
that mean
you guys are walking
in the same direction.
So I had to go take care of myself.
And because I'm
a leader and I'm leading man
and I'm leading, you know,
women and children is
just like I have to have clarity
and be a
my mind right man
for the decisions I make. Right.
And I wasn't that way in the beginning
because I had so much trauma.
But I'm not all the way here yet.
I'm still working his work in progress,
but I do feel that
I'm in a better state
than I've ever been.
Do you worry about
the words in rap, the words in hip hop?
I mean, look,
you have Tupac
and then you have, you know, Lil Jon
or you have
you know, you
can you can go down
a number of voices in hip hop,
and some of them are really deep.
That's poetic.
It tells a story
about what
they've been through, trying to help
other
people have been through the same thing.
But then you also have
misogyny, violence, drug selling.
Do you worry about the words in hip hop
that that are going out to the masses
and making it seem glamorous,
I think is just
the message is is,
you know,
because I can't be the one to talk
because I spoke
on everything that I went through
but it was my truth, you know?
And I feel like
the reality is, is not on us.
It's on America.
You know me. It is not.
We can't control no environment.
It's like we put in these projects,
in these buildings,
in these neighborhoods,
and we don't have the right tools
and the way resources.
So we have to survive.
So all these stories
you're hearing are people
that are coming out of these situations
in these environments,
telling their story
and hoping that they can connect
with other people. Right.
Because it's therapeutic
for them as well.
But as you say, like Tupac's and Cool,
that's what changed my life.
He was my therapist.
Heaney you know,
he was a lot of people said, yeah, and
and the reason why I had rules
and I had a moral compass and values
is because I listen to what podcast.
I didn't just listen to the music.
I listened to what he said.
So as I began to get into the series,
I was I had a moral compass already
and I was hoping
that's what my music was doing,
giving him a moral compass.
Because even if my music was negative
in the beginning,
it was always a message in it.
Got to believe Doug motivation,
the inspiration, the recession.
You know,
there's always something in there
that has something to do
with evolving or either
growing or staying motivated.
I think
I got to tell you,
sitting down with him,
there is a reason why
his book is a bestseller,
a New York Times bestseller.
His first line in the book says,
I was a thief.
And he goes on from there.
And he is so raw and real and,
you know, must never hear somebody
from the community of hip hop
talking about mental illness,
mental health, the problems had.
He's an incredible person,
not just a famous rapper.
It's important that he's doing that.
Yeah, really interesting guy.